from whale mouths to whale memories and
curie's consequential connection the
tahilu is on Full display in avatar The
Way of water and as complicated Beyond
connection when Avatar first came out in
2009 many were quick to draw comparisons
between it and Pocahontas or dancers
with Wolves the movie still manages to
set itself apart in terms of its
spectacular World building James Cameron
and his team created an entire world and
language filled with new animals and
Customs making the movie feel truly
lived in the navi felt like a real
civilization complete with religion
based on something real in the world of
Pandora an RV worship awar which is
based on the real normal connections at
all of the fauna and Flora on the planet
remain connected to and an avatar the
way of water they aren't as simple
anymore while in the first film the navi
can tap into this awar via the tahelu
which requires them to connect their
ponytails with other materials to allow
them to feel and communicate with what
the other plants or animal is feeling
however there's much more to learn about
this ability and Avatar the way of water
reveals more ways than RV can bond with
those around them they'll be introduced
to a new oceanic Clan and an array of
diverse aquatic creatures bonding plays
an important part in avatar The Way of
water as Jake Sully and they Theory ride
Mountain banshees to get around once the
two take their family to the Met Karina
Clan they learn how to bond with elus
and skin Wings which basically function
as their forest-based counterparts
allowing the navi to travel with ease
however the main animal on display in
the way of water is the tolkun which is
a giant whale-like creature but it has a
very unique way of bonding instead of
attaching to an ultra exposed mechanism
like in the first avatar the navi must
enter the tolkun's mouth only there will
they find the normal Point as we see
with loac and pyacan a young tolkun he
befriends however lowack doesn't use his
connection to control player Khan
instead he sees a player Khan saw in one
fateful day which just so happens to be
the reason why the Mets kaina and other
tolkunes nothing to do with him they
view him as a killer which goes against
the tolkun way up until this point we
hadn't seen that bonding could lead to
such a phenomenon lowak actually watches
payakan's memories allowing greater
depth and understanding within their
bond kiwi has our own unique experience
with bonding but with almost tragic
consequences some kids from the Mets
kaina Clan take Kerry to a special place
in The Reef where she can bond with a
unique structure when she connects to it
she receives an image and ahead of her
speaking to the human form of Dr Grace
Augustine however things take a dark
turn when kiwi begins seizing underwater
forcing her new friends to take her to
the surface for raid it's unclear
exactly why bonding caused Kiri to have
a seizure in this instance although Dr
Norm Spellman and Dr Max Patel insist
that it was a form of epilepsy with the
bonding acting as a kind of trigger
Sigourney Weaver who plays Curie in the
film did say in an interview with Scream
ransack Kiri was more deeply connected
to Nature than others around her so it's
possible that had something to do with
the reaction as she explained there is a
scene where she talks about hearing a
while's breathing awar is why Kyrie can
hear things that other people don't hear
I think it makes Kiri quite
uncomfortable but I think because she's
so sensitive to all of nature that she
would also be sensitive to awar clearly
there's more to bonding than simply
being able to ride an animal around like
a pony with plenty of sequels reportedly
on Deck chances a good will learn more
about bonding in the years to come
[Music]